Chut, il ne faut pas parler trop fort parce qu'on est dimanche et le dimanche je sais que vous dormez,
vous vous reveillez dans votre lit pour regarder L'EXPLICATION DU DIMANCHE !
Aujourd'hui, comme tous les dimanches, je vous explique quelque chose qui va vous permettre de
bluffer votre entourage,  aujourd'hui ou dans la semaine, peu importe !
On va partir sur un forçage psychologique
C'est pas exactement ce que je voulais faire, ce dimanche,
du coup je garde l'idée pour la semaine prochaine
où je vous apprendrai à trouver à quel prénom pense quelqu'un
et ce ne sera pas un tour de magie, on sera vraiment dans du mentalisme
mais cette semaine j'ai eu une autre idée, en discutant un peu avec vous
dans les commentaires, quelqu'un a parlé de quelque chose
je ne vous dis pas encore quoi sinon ça va gâcher la surprise,
et je me suis dit : "mais ça, vous.... il y en a qui ne connaissent pas, ça ?"
et il y en a plein qui m'ont dit : "oui, on ne connait pas on ne connait pas..."
et je pensais que c'était ultra connu.
On va commencer, je vais déjà vous faire la démonstation
si vous connaissez, ne vous inquiétez pas, allez jusqu'au bout
parce que je vais vous expliquer pourquoi ça marche, et comment faire en sorte que ça marche encore mieux
et à 100%, ou en tout cas proche des 100%
le 100% n'existe pas dans le mentalisme
et si vous ne connaissez pas, eh bien ENJOY ! (appréciez)
Dans un premier temps, vous allez vous concentrer,
vous allez jouer le jeu avec moi,
vous restez bien concentrés sur la vidéo,
si vous avez des écouteurs c'est encore mieux
ne vous laissez surtout pas distraire.
Vous allez répondre le plus rapidement possible, à voix haute,
alors si c'est compliqué de parler parce que vous êtes dans le métro, vous chuchotez
mais vous répondez vraiment à voix haute
à des petits calculs arithmétiques simples que je vais vous faire.
On commence soft, c'est parti attention ça va être très rapide.
2 + 2 ?
2 + 3 ?
1+1 ?
2x5 ?
Attention plus dur : 7+4
9+2 ?
Et maintenant, instantanément sans réflechir, je veux que vous chuchotiez ou que vous disiez
à voix haute, un outil et une couleur, maintenant !
tout de suite : un outil, et une couleur.
Et là, je vous remercie d'avoir bien voulu penser à un "marteau rouge". Évidemment !
Peut-être que certains d'entre vous ont pensé à autre chose.
À un tournevis par exemple, ou à la couleur bleue ou encore à des choses complètement hallucinantes
Si c'est le cas dites le moi dans les commentaires pour qu'on se marre.
Mais le taux de réussite en suivant la méthode de base de demander spontanément à quelqu'un :
un outil et une couleur, est de 78%
mais on peut passer la barre des 90% voire même plus en appliquant deux astuces :
La première astuce, c'est de saturer le cerveau rationnel (on dit qu'il y a le cerveau droit et le cerveaux gauche, ça c'est des images)
mais notre but c'est de saturer d'information le cerveau rationnel pour avoir accès à l'inconscient
(je vous dis pourquoi juste après)
Donc pour le saturer, il faut l'occuper et vous allez
l'occuper avec des opérations très simples.
Mais ça, c'est pour faire focaliser le conscient
et le rationnel là-dessus.
Une fois qu'il est bien occupé, vous demandez une réponse
spontanée. Vous pressez la personne.
Vous claquez des doigts en même temps. Vous dites : "Maintenant.
Maintenant. Dis-moi un outil, une couleur."
Notre but, c'est qu'elle réfléchisse pas. Si elle réfléchit, elle va
repasser par le rationnel et ça ne nous
intéresse pas du tout puisqu'on veut avoir l'inconscient.
Si on laisse les manettes à l'inconscient, spontanément,
il va répondre "marteau" et "rouge".
Pourquoi la couleur rouge ? parce que c'est la première couleur qui nous vient,
c'est la couleur essentielle dans notre vie,
tout ce qui est important depuis l'école a été souligné en rouge ou écrit en rouge
tout ce qui est important ou interdit est mis en rouge,
tous les panneaux de circulation vraiment dangereux ou d'interdiction sont mis en rouge,
le sang c'est rouge, donc ca représente la vie, ça représente la mort,
on est marqués par le rouge.
C'est pas la couleur préférée, forcément,
mais c'est une couleur assez marquante
pour que l'inconscient la ressorte tout de suite.
Et pourquoi marteau ? Parce que la plupart d'entre nous,
on est pas des grands bricoleurs, on bricole pas souvent,
quand vous le faites des fois à des vrais gros bricoleurs vous avez des surprises
Donc le marteau c'est le premier outil dont on s'est servi,
la première action manuelle qu'on a tous effectué c'est de taper sur quelque chose,
depuis notre plus tendre enfance.
même si on est pas bricoleurs, on a déjà tapé sur quelque chose
pour la faire rentrer. Donc quand on dit : "outil",
on pense à "manuel".  et quand on pense à "manuel",
on pense à ce qu'on attrape, et le geste le plus simple qu'on peut faire
avec un objet qu'on attrape, c'est taper. C'est donc le marteau.
et voici pourquoi spontanément, tout le monde dit : "marteau rouge".
pour le présenter vous pouvez le prédire,
en l'écrivant à l'avance sur un papier,
vous pouvez en faire aussi un test psychologique,
vous pouvez faire la présentation que vous voulez,
c'est très drôle. Forcément, vous ne pourrez le faire qu'une seule fois
à chaque personne, une fois que c'est fait c'est cramé, vous ne le referez plus jamais.
c'est pour ça que les quelques personnes qui regardaient la vidéoet
qui connaissaient déjà n'ont pas pu le refaire,
et je pensais que c'était extrêmement connu,
et en discutant avec vous dans les commentaires,
j'étais très étonné de voir qu'il y avait beaucoup de personnes qui ne connaissaient pas.
d'ou l'objet de cette vidéo de dimanche.
Je vous ai donc déjà annoncé ce que j'allais vous expliquer
dimanche prochain, mais il va se passer de toute manière  plein de choses cette semaine,
Un grand merci, je ne le fais pas tout les jours mais vraiment merci
à tous ceux qui sous-titrent les vidéos,
c'est vraiment cool, ça permet aux malentendants de pouvoir suivre
toutes ces vidéos là,
et c'est vous qui faites tout le taf', donc merci, merci à vous ! (mais de rien c'est un plaisir :-)
bah là, regardez, c'est moi qui vous met un pouce en l'air !
et si vous avez aimé la vidéo, vous pouvez en mettre un en retour
demain dans la journée je vous poserai une question
je ne sais pas encore si je vais la poser sur Facebook,Twitter, Instagram,
ou Snapchat, je verrai.
En tout cas je relayerai l'info sur les autres réseaux sociaux,
pour vous dire où répondre pour cumuler toutes les réponses
au même endroit, ce sera pour faire une vidéo jeudi avec
vous et beaucoup grâce à vous.
Passez un excellent dimanche,  n'oubliez pas de vous abonner à la chaîne
avant de partir, le mental vlog c'est une vidéo par jour pendant un an,
alors rendez-vous demain, à 17h pour le prochain mental vlog, CIAO !